[Music]
we're seeing in unprecedented epidemic
of depression in our society more people
are being diagnosed with depression than
ever including millions of children the
latest statistics I've seen are that
more than one in ten Americans is on
prescribed antidepressant medication one
in four of us is on psychiatric
medication of one sort or another again
including millions of children and I
would just say we really have no idea
what these drugs do to developing brains
so we're doing a vast experiment with
our nation's children there's also a
great rise and anxiety disorders which
often overlap with depression with
insomnia so by all indications mental
and emotional health in our population
is not good and it's declining when I
ask people why they think this is so a
common answer I get is that well look at
the economy look at the state of the
world but my parents grew up in the
Great Depression which makes our
economic troubles look pretty tame and
they also lived through World War two
which is probably the most terrific
human experience in history and by all
accounts American emotional well-being
was much better during those periods so
something's happened and I think it
really cries out for explanation the
conventional way of dealing with this is
all focused on correcting imbalances in
brain biochemistry this is the
biomedical model which sees all mind
processes as being the results of brain
biochemistry and therefore the only
intervention that's thought of us to use
pharmaceutical drugs to change brain
chemistry I think that model has proved
very limited in its effectiveness
there's a growing body of evidence that
the most commonly used antidepressant
drugs the SSRIs work no better than
placebos in most cases of mild to
moderate depression so I would say that
model has really failed us in trying to
think what to do about this I did a lot
of research on the patterns of emotional
well-being and
and throughout the world one thing I
found is that that there's a great
consistency of research reports that
depression is virtually unknown in the
few hunter-gatherer societies left on
the planet you can't find a case of
major depression in Papua New Guinea for
example so that invites the question you
know what are those societies doing
different from us and the answer is
everything
no they are not disconnected from nature
they're eating diets that are natural
not highly processed they're getting
plenty of physical activity they get
adequate rest and sleep I think very
significantly they enjoy the protection
a very strong tribal and community
support so for all those reasons I think
they're protected and when you look at
what's changed in our society I think
you can see several trends our diet has
become very different from that of our
grandparents you know we're no longer
eating foods in the forms that nature
produced them they're highly refined and
processed most of us lead sedentary
lives we're very disconnected from
nature and live in artificial
environments I think social isolation
has increased tremendously in our
culture I think that's very significant
and we're also subjected to an
unprecedented amount of stimulation from
all the new media and technological
devices for communication email texting
the internet it's a matter of looking at
total lifestyle and to design a program
to protect and enhance emotional
well-being it really has to look at all
aspects of lifestyle you know everything
under our control exercise physical
activity rest sleep how you handle
stress how you eat nature of social
relations you know all that so I'd
invite you to continue watching big
think mentor to learn the specific
aspects of the program
that I recommend for attaining optimum
emotional well-being
[Music]